rich how are you doing can you hear me
okay yeah you're coming in loud and
clear great great so it was a great show
tonight it's real clear
actionable advice so i think i'm in a
situation a lot of guys are in that are
on this uh channel and on this uh cast
right now where we're not entrepreneurs
yet we may very well want to be that
we're here because we've kind of made a
decision with your content that we want
to take more control we're tired of
maybe listening to other people and want
to kind of forge our own path but i'm in
a situation where i'm not ready to move
on to that level and i think it might be
kind of a
maybe not even the same thing at all to
say how do you operate with an
entrepreneur mindset in a corporate or
company
until you're ready to make that jump i'm
sure maybe your sales guys have done it
yeah so we used to call those people
intrapreneurs yeah because you're
because you're in a corporation
um
and
see
the number one skill i believe that that
you need to possess as an entrepreneur
that's that's that's going to contribute
to your success and your growth and your
wealth is you have to have problem
solving skills i mean you have to know
how to deal with people and there's all
kinds of stuff as well but you have to
be a really good problem solver because
all that running a business really is
especially for the first few years
solving a lot of problems yeah and
you can
be great at it in a corporation
the problem is they adopt very little of
it because they're very slow to move
they're not agile they want their t's
crossed their eyes dotted hang on we got
to get legal to look at this one before
we do anything and blah blah blah right
that's why
that's why you can have this like large
organization that's listed on the nasdaq
that gets blown by by like
three 21 year olds with the case of red
bull and some boners they just kind of
zip right by everybody sort of thing
because they're so agile and fast and
there's no red tape right so you know to
answer your question you know
specifically is i would just say just
get very good at solving problems and
look for opportunities in your industry
i mean for me when i was in the
collection industry i saw a void because
all i saw was
large companies that would call people
to basically harass them to pay their
bills
uh then there was bankruptcy trustees
which didn't which wasn't a very good
solution there was credit counselors
which was another shitty solution so i
knew about settling debt brokering a
deal between the creditor and the debtor
and i created that business it didn't
exist and that's part of the reason why
we had such massive growth you know
during that time
so it's you know the right place the
right time you know all that stuff adds
up but you got to be good at solving
problems so look for ways to solve
problems in the business keep a little
notepad maybe you'll find something that
you know that you jot down that could be
a business idea later on down the road
maybe you're forced to go home because
of whatever reason or maybe you decide
to quit because you're fed up you know
you could have a notepad of ideas that
say all right you know what i'm kind of
tired of doing the corporate thing i'm
gonna go do my own thing now here and i
like number three on the list yeah you
know what there's a good book that i'll
recommend to you guys that that are
um in the same mind frame as you are
right now it's called choose yourself
and the author is james altucher
yeah
okay
yeah uh appreciate that one last thing
though i want to throw out concerning
this a lot of guys are talking about
university and i i want to ask you this
from your perspective
are you do you think a lot of guys
overvalue a degree and undervalue what
experience means to an employer like
yourself and do you think that guys
don't know how to sell or understand the
value that they've already put in the
work for and they don't know how to sell
it yeah
yeah um
a lot of um guys you know myself
included were led to believe you need to
have good grades to be successful in
life yeah um
you don't
most
most entrepreneurs that i
knew you know myself included were like
c average students
we didn't get a pluses in school the
school system is not designed for
entrepreneurs it's designed to teach you
to to sit still
pay attention
you know write down what's on the
overhead or the projector you know take
your notes cross your t's dot your eyes
color within the lines like they started
in geography right i don't know if you
did this in geography class but they
gave you a green crayon and a blue
crayon and on the land masses you would
have to color on the inside green and on
the water you would have to color it
blue like they like they legitimately
teach
students to follow rules and color with
an alliance and that's not what leads to
successful entrepreneurship you have to
think outside of the box they often said
that steve jobs didn't even see the box
you know when it came to thinking right
but you go through the school system
you're going to be conditioned to think
inside the box conventionally
so you have to be careful i have a lot
of friends that
you know though they worry about not
having a degree and i and i sit there i
talk about their resume and i look at it
whatsoever there's no pieces of paper on
my wall framed in mahogany with little
letters after my name yeah but i make a
[ __ ] ton more money than a lot of people
i know with mahogany degrees with little
letters after the name in fact i employ
some people with mahogany degrees with
little letters after the name to do my
accounting to do my legal work right
like they work for me right so
you know
i'm not saying don't know accounting
like don't understand like accounting
principles you should understand them
you know you should know how to
reconcile and and what each ledger is
for
but i'm going to pay an accountant to do
my taxes i'm not going to do it i got
better [ __ ] to do with my time
fair enough well hey i appreciate it
yeah thanks
you